جندي دولي اخر في صفوف فرق الانقاذ التي
تغوص بين اكوام الركام في تركيا وسوريا
بحثا عن المفقودين اصبح وجوده جزءا لا
يتجزا في عمليه العثور على المحاصرين بين
الانقاض كائنات تجازف كما الانسان بحياتها
من اجل الاخرين لكن تدريب الكلاب امر لازم
لتهيئتها في مثل هذه الكوارث فكيف توظف
هيئه الاغاثه هذا الحيوان المفضل عالميا
في جهود المساعده نبدا من ولادته حيث
تساهم امه في تحفيز الخلايا العصبيه عبر
لمس الجرو الذي يدخل في التنشئه
الاجتماعيه تليها مرحله يتدخل فيها البشر
ينتقون الكلاب وهي في عمر لا يتجاوز
ثمانيه اسابيع لبدء تجهيزها للمهام الصعبه
ثم يعرضون هذه الجراء لاشخاص وحيوانات
وبيئات مختلفه مما يساعدها على الشعور
بالراحه في المواقف الجديده فالتدريب الذي
تخضع له كلاب الانقاذ صارم وواسع النطاق
وبما انها تمتلك حاسه شم قويه يحاول
المدربون ان ينموا هذه المهاره الى ان
تستطيع الكلاب تمييز رائحه البشر الحي
منهم والميت وفي حالات الزلازل يتم
تمرينهم على البحث في الحطام وتسلق
السلالم والتنقل في المساحات الضيقه
وحينما تشك الكلاب بوجود انسان حي في تلال
الدمار تلك قد تنبح او تنبش الارض لتنبيه
الفريق بان احدهم هنا واذا استدعى الامر
يجلبون كلبا اخر لتاكيد الموقع ثم تسخير
اليات عملهم على مكان بعينه بروتو في
زلزال تركيا وفريده في المكسيك مثالاني
على ابطال حقيقيين ليسوا شجعانا في
الكوارث فحسب بل ان الكلاب تسترق السمع
وتستشعر انفاسا حجاره جافيه على اجساد
الاطفال
اسراء الصغير العربيه